ja heute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video
ich habe heute noch etwas länger zeit
mal wieder meine freundin marie dabei
und zwar machen wir heute was ganz
spezielles ich habe euch auf inseln
gefragt leute schickt mir doch einfach
mal eure lieblings amazon produkte ja
weil ich kann mich jetzt nicht daran
erinnern dass man das ist sowas schon
mal gegeben hat ich habe vorher auch
nicht nach herkunft aber wir gehen
einfach mal davon aus dass wir die
ersten sind die das machen
jetzt kamen wirklich sehr viel feedback
und ich habe einfach mal fünf produkte
bestellt die mich interessiert haben
oder sechs vielleicht auch die probleme
jetzt die probleme jetzt aus und da sind
hier um alle bei unfällen mit anfangen
mit dem länglichen nach vorne dass leute
das hier ist das erste produkt ich
bleibe euch hier immer ein was die leute
geschrieben haben ich weiß ja ungefähr
noch weil ich habe das gerade erst mal
vor drei vier tagen gestellt hast du
bevor ich es vergesse für den zweiten
part ihr können wir auch super gerne
eure lieblings amazon brücke also
irgendwie eine sache die immer schilder
vordenker wie geil ist das denn
das müsst ihr euch zum ausprobieren
schick mir dass übergänge ins ländle
heißt ich alex wie marie heißt könnt ihr
euch hier eventuell auch in minute passt
und wir starten jetzt mit den hier nicht
gerne arzt und amazon
das habe ich ja noch nie gesehen dass in
einer fand aufkleber ach so weil das
kommen nicht aus deutschland und damit
diese dosen halt recycelt werden kann
man das draufkleben folgte
so jetzt kann ich auch in diese
automatisch aber da komme ich raus nein
wirst du putzt ich habe da ich mir die
haare mit mind ich wusste nicht dass das
logo klebte reinpumpen dir das jetzt zu
erklären
hier haben wir hier seht ihr auch hier
drauf auf der seite mit bier ich meine
ich hätte das schon mal probiert und ich
fand es extrem lecker
deswegen habe ich das einfach mal stellt
führen das haben wir auch in new york
frankfurt
soweit ich weiss kommt es auf jeden fall
aus amerika und das hat seinen ganz
speziellen geschmack ähnlich klingt das
ein bisschen also das wird mir was wir
getroffen haben hat nicht so gestanden
war irgendwas erinnert mich dieser
robert verschimmelt das schmeckt gar
nicht gut aber also ich weiß dass
irgendwie eigentlich lecker alles
schmeckt ist nicht schlecht das riecht
nach kennt ihr diese schleuse schlank
buch made with external hast du so lange
gereift ist valess flavour aber ich bin
das nicht geil ich glaube es gibt noch
keine das gutbier was besser schnell ich
will das jetzt auch nicht empfehlen das
heute kauf also wissen lieblingsprodukt
das auch immer ist da muss ich noch mal
fragen was sind mit den
geschmacksknospen los okay dass leute
das heutige video enthält freundlich
unterstützung von nord vpn ich ja gleich
mal kurz was ein vpn ist was eure
vorteile sind wenn ihr ein vpn benutzt
und warum man sich auf jeden fall für
nord vpn entscheiden sollte
ausgeschrieben steht das ganze für
virtual private network oder wenn man es
ins deutsche übersetzt virtuelles
privates netzwerk also der name sagt sie
eigentlich schon kurz gesagt ein vpn
ermöglicht euch geschützt im
öffentlichen netzwerk zu surfen damit
wird ihr internetverkehr verschlüsselt
und eure online identität verschleiert
somit ist es für dritte nicht
nachvollziehbar also die daten werden
komplett zusammengestellt und niemand
kann sie mir auslesen das ganze passiert
in echtzeit und eure spuren im internet
werden verwischt klingt denke ich erst
mal ganz cool und welche vorteile nord
vpn noch mit sich zieht das sage ich
euch jetzt ihr könnt auf über 5500
superschnelle server in 60 ländern
zugreifen wenn ihr im ausland seid und
eure lieblings serie auf jedem
x-beliebigen streaming anbieter nicht
streamen können
aus rechtlichen gründen halt mit nord
vpn gar kein problem weil es beispiel
ich war anfang letzten jahres in new
york und konnte über sky keine
bundesliga schauen weil ich halt in
amerika saß notfahrplan macht's möglich
keine aufzeichnung von nutzerdaten eure
daten werden auf sämtlichen reisen
geschützt und so weiter und so fort und
um das ganze cool abzuschließen für alle
leute die auch so wie ich viele
verschiedene accounts auf verschiedenen
webseiten haben dann mal wieder daran
passwort vergessen und da wieder ein
fast schon vergessen haben sich diese
ganzen passwörter auch ungern
irgendwohin schreiben würden dann
empfehle ich euch mal nord passt auch
eine dienstreise sofort vpn und dann
habt ihr diese probleme eigentlich nicht
mehr checks das ganze auf jeden fall ab
mit dem gutscheincode alex wie gibt es
noch ordentlich rabatt um in der video
beschreibung verlinke ich euch alle
weiteren infos und wir machen jetzt
weiter mit dem video
let's go was ist das alexa travel smart
sieht aus wie eine trinkflasche ich
glaub ich weiß was es ist das ist also
ich muss sagen ich finde das extrem
villa gezogen ja dass ich so was wird
das ist eine trinkflasche ja und zeigt
dir die temperatur an die drinnen
herrscht das heißt denn wenn du jetzt
kaffee da drin hast dann und der zu heiß
ist dann weißt du schon vor
da musst du nicht so ganz vorsichtig
trinken und dann weißt du hast war es
mein haar man einfach ganz heißen tee
einfach so direkt trinken welche die
märkte nicht kannst ja auch der run auf
eine herdplatte legen aktuell testen das
jetzt mal so ich mache jetzt einfach mal
wasser weil das wasser hat so nämlich x
10 watt ok mal gucken ob das
funktioniert dann schrauben wir das mal
zu das war als kaltes wasser
das ist halt immer so und dann wird das
wieder ein bild 19 watt hat dass das
danach
das glaube ich nicht kalt können schon
19 mal sein doch stimmt wenn man zb geht
hatten sehr auch öfters man gerade im
osten sonntag wartet dann nehme ich
jetzt mal heißt das wasser also jetzt
haben wir wirklich mal so schätzen und
50 grad
der kalte schon halt so heißt ja ich
habe es richtig heiß gemacht und wenn er
jetzt wieder 20 an 28 28
ich schätze es nicht falsch ich glaube
das hat so kann man 30 bis jetzt nein
wenn ich mich das unterstelle würde ich
verbrennung krieg und weil sie nicht
richtig ja immer so heiß und du musst
halt immer relativ waren nur weil du
sehr empfindlich ist
was macht es schon heiser als 32 grad
und hey du da könnte ich schon drin
duschen lisicki sie aber das sind heiße
als 92 grad
russland 11 grad das passt das passt zu
100 prozentig du schon mal so bei 36
grad und das war ziemlich normal
ja okay das haben wir 33 das kommt schon
hin dass dinge wissen immer so
stichprobenartig und wieso solche
thermometer nicht funktionieren das ist
jetzt keine absolute neue technik
deswegen gehen wir einfach mal davon aus
dass das stimmt auch wenn ich bisher in
dumpfer gerade das tut mir leid dass wir
wieder den momentan alles worum ich
würde sagen absoluter willen also dieses
thema halte ich denn da hab dieses ding
finde ich sehr nahe da oder empfehlungen
daumen nach oben ok weiter geht es mit
dem nächsten produkt kommt man hat hier
sogar auch noch so eine tasche dabei
damit dann der heiße kaffee oder der
heiße tipp auch war bleibt dann kannst
du hast hier so wie hier von geislingen
alter von das war auch gar nicht teuer
das hat nur 13 euro oder so gepolt ist
ja mega nein leute das hier ist eine
aufblasbare schwebe also du kannst dich
reinlegen du kannst sie mitnehmen sowie
und dann am strand oder am see der
hauptschule ja sowieso oft aber hier
stehen anwalt
heute steht das irgendwas nächsten so
dass auch hier steht jetzt traut man
muss diese vorderseite öffnen dann
richtung wind laufen damit sie sich
automatisch auf legt aber wir haben
hey leute dieses ding ist so ein job
mehr also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
dass es funktioniert das hat auch nur
dreieinhalb sterne aber ich dachte man
kann das auch tust und wir haben das
jetzt schon wirklich lange fassung ich
zeige es euch nochmals und dann sollte
einfach der wind rein das ist einfach
unmöglich also es muss tornado sein dass
das irgendwie funktioniert man kann es
an fahren macht hängen jetzt halt das
nochmal vor allem es ist gar nicht mal
so wünschte also wir haben schon wind
jetzt halt das mal auf noch mal du
stehst aber vorm winter kann er jetzt
nicht rein und jetzt rennen trinkt gerne
selbst in so ein scheiß auf und das kann
man bestimmt auch bei uns bestellt so
leute das war ein flop oder keine ahnung
wer wird sich sowas kauft aber gut jetzt
glaube ich mal dass das dann
funktioniert darf ich jetzt das nächste
willen haben und zwar hat das ein und
dass jemand das empfohlen habe das weiß
ich noch ziemlich um dieses video wo ich
mal gedacht habe in seinem amazon paket
werden drogen und da meinte der
bestellung mal dass das bestelle ich
immer und das zeige ich dir jetzt mal an
drogen dann war so neugierig deswegen
muss ich das schon einmal reingucken
wenn euch jemand das produkt einmal ein
und das sieht dann so aus hier das kam
da drin und dann dachte ich schon so
hell was ist schon so ein kleines café
sowie das auszugeben was auf mit zu
offen wir mal gespannt
das ist aber nicht das ist klar das ist
kein echtes gras ist auf jeden fall
sondern so ohne thc das wird in
österreich angebaut und das beruhigt
dich halt ich weiß jetzt nicht genau wie
es wirkt aber das ist natürlich ein
es ist halt illegal deswegen
das ausprobieren klar wieso nicht das
ist ja das ist legal
das ist ganz klar ja noch möglich dass
auch aus der haft weil es mir egal ist
auch du bist nur nach vorschrift hier
marilena vorschrift im niedrigen also
ich werde euch im nächsten part werde
ich euch bei meiner erfahrung wir
möchten sie zur untermalung aus mir auch
schon dann kommt schon relativ nah dran
aber wenn das irgendwas schlimmes ist
dass man eigentlich gar nichts zu sich
nehmen seite doch ich habe das schon mal
gemacht in österreich man letzter ist
ein wissen das weil das in der
beschreibung stand und ich hab's von
amazon bestellt ich könnte mal essen das
künstler machen warum es nicht ja das
ist die ganze sache dass da bin ich sehr
gespannt das gibt's ja das gibt es nicht
im laden so weit ich weiß wohin gehört
das ist dann ein paar schlucke bon scott
wie sieht's aus wie kinder abholen und
mit schoko ich habe das aufholen noch
nie gesehen und da haben zwei leute
geschickt und dann dachte ich mir das
muss ich auf jeden fall werde stellung
er kommt ja das kommt auf jeden fall
nicht aus deutschland nicht mal hier
hinten auf kommt vielleicht aus saudi
arabien untersucht ja auf jeden fall so
arabische schriftzeichen
wir sind auch viel größer als normale
alltag das ist wie ein kinder kinder
sein die sodinger das ist genauso offen
gesagt das ist life changing leiter der
hat immer nur diese dinger so sollten
alter ist etwas das ist mein gewinner
aus der heutigen folge meyer
er hat uns richtig geil
doch langsam nach oben das war jetzt
schluss machen ich würde sagen ihr
schicken wir jetzt eure favorite amazon
produkt so aber wirklich nur das beste
und dann testen wir das im nächsten part
ich hoffe ich habe lust darauf lasse
sondern um da abonniert sich in den
kanal und wir sehen uns die tage wieder
gibt's neues video das war's
maries kanal klein ist wahrscheinlich
kann man nicht so genau sagen kommt
drauf an ob sie es schafft das
zuschneiden oder sich leute bis dann
haut rein dann bist du schon ciao